he just took off and ran
I know he's scared out there and breaks
my heart
let's go find him
this time on trackers I hear a bark a
best friend vanishes
fear takes over are you kidding
that's right Jake as danger Loom Emma
come on baby girl miles from home nobody
else
foreign
[Music]
most tracking dogs are intelligent and
quick
[Music]
some are like Jake are also loud and
playful
Jake is very very opinionated no matter
what else is going on can you make sure
he is hurt
Carmen Brothers is one of Jake's
handlers when she comes to pick him up
it's time to go to work Jake and I make
an awesome team
together we have helped over 65 pet
owners reunite with their pets Jake you
ready to go find Emma okay
tracking Duo is headed to Western
Maryland in search of a lost chihuahua
named Emma
Emma is very very loving she loves
people that she knows she's not super
friendly with strangers she likes to lay
up around your neck and cuddle with you
you know she's she's a very loving
affectionate little dog
she actually lives with my ex-husband
but I was watching her for the weekend
she got out
we searched from you know eight in the
morning to 10 30 at night and still
couldn't locate her so it's been hard
because we know she's been out there for
two nights by herself
Stacy had to break the news to her
ex-husband Mike who is six hours away on
vacation
so I had to call and tell him that I
can't she got out I couldn't find her
he was upset I could tell he
maybe wanted to cry on the phone because
she is so tidy and so she's so little
and my biggest concern is
how am I gonna tell it this we don't
find her alive
[Music]
while she has been missing for two days
there is a solid lead for The Trackers
they had a sighting last night actually
of her right by a very busy highway
so it's a
very dangerous situation all around so
I'm trying to get there as quickly as
possible
Emma was seen nearly two miles from
Stacy's home
the track begins here
this is a very very dangerous location
for for Emma to be at
it's very challenging it doesn't get
much worse than highways and train
tracks parallel it it's just days or all
around
Jake is a black and tan coonhound a
breed developed in the Southern United
States to hunt small animals like
raccoons and possums so take it out of
the bag try not to touch it we'll send
him up and see what happens this blanket
is covered in Emma's hair and skin
particles
Jake's powerful scent receptors pick up
the Chihuahua's unique smell
immediately Jake is on the trail
[Music]
Jake working dogs often receive commands
in a foreign language
signals that Jake must Focus his loud
and playful personality
the air sense as well as you know ground
sense
this capacity enables Jake to follow a
ground Trail and if for any reason the
trail is lost he can detect Airborne
particles and get back on track
two ways notice points
yeah that's better than what it was back
there
guys what is that running up the track
wait
did you see that is that Emma that is
Emma guys nobody else
baby he's right there he's headed over
15.
Emma come on baby girl
[Applause]
Emma
Emma come on baby girl
he's right down there on the side Emma
is in flight mode don't run hey fear has
caused her to revert back to her
instinctive nature and focus only on
Survival she's down that way
she may not even recognize Stacy's voice
there could be disastrous so close to
the highway
okay so here we're gonna do I'm gonna
take Jake I'm hoping that if I walk Jake
parallel down 15 where we just work I'm
going to push her back this way okay so
we can get her away from the highway
okay and then we can kind of determine
which how far down she's gone and where
to go from there
articulated risk the site of Jake should
scare the Chihuahua away from the
highway and Into the Woods
thank you
oh my adrenaline's pumping right now I
was feeling really anxious my heart's
racing
um I just wanna hopefully we can flush
her out
and get her get her home
the Bloodhound is an iconic tracker and
trustee the epitome of the breed
my husband wanted
I just I didn't want any of it
reluctantly Wendy gave Bloodhounds a try
eventually building a partnership with a
scrappy young Pup Named trustee she was
probably about three months old when I
started tracking with her she just loved
it pop it in girl
foreign
weekend well thank you look Wendy and
trusty are headed out into the summer
heat
in search of a missing mini labradoodle
named Logan
we got him at six weeks old he's been my
best friend every single day I look
forward coming home just so be greeted
by him we were having a party at our
house for Fourth of July
there was people in the neighborhood
doing fireworks and my husband has
somebody it's like where's Logan
the doll got out he just darted off and
you know never turned around
the first night I sat in the garage all
night on a chair didn't sleep at all the
next day we just got up looked for you
know 16 hours straight
the first time he's ever been you know
out on his own without us
I decided to find my dog have him home
safe
can't believe this happened
trustee and I are going over there you
know with this weekend being a long
weekend the fireworks aren't going to
give up they're just going to keep
coming so Logan's getting scared again
he's going to continue to run
certain articles there have been no
sightings of Logan okay Bob and Kelly
are relying on trustee
well let me get her and we'll take it
from there trustee will lead the way
it's okay come on
[Music]
so she just air scented that she can
smell from this block to another like we
could track to a house over there just
by the scent of it
trustee may not be as spirited as Jake
but her tracking ability is unparalleled
Bloodhounds are said to be cold nosed
tractors meaning they can pick up on
tracks that are too old for most dogs
two blocks from home she takes an
interest in a basement stairwell
she sniffed around in circles about four
or five times
and then she ended up
sitting down and then laid down
more than likely Logan spent some time
down there hiding overnight possibly
after an hour the blistering heat begins
to take its toll on the veteran working
dog
Wendy stops down to take care of her
partner
oh does it feel good
I feel good
typically dogs can only get rid of
excess Heat by panting
evaporating water in this cooling vest
will help trusty keeper temperature down
so she can keep tracking Logan
he sells nothing
[Music]
here a park
did you say that sounds like his bark it
sounds like his bark is very God does
I heard a bark I heard the bark again
listen
that is his bark Logan
he's right down there on the side
don't run hey so I've got a big problem
Jake and his Handler Carmen are
searching for Emma a lost chihuahua
we didn't have any children our dogs are
our babies she's down that way
so it's been hard because we know she's
been out there for two nights by herself
Jake's pulling double duty
he's tracking Emma's scent and in a
sense shepherding
Carmen's hoping his presence will prompt
the terrified Chihuahua to run away from
the Busy Highway
hopefully Jake will make
him make a point
this strategy pays off Jake tracks left
signaling Carmen's plan to chase Emma
into the woods is working
we uh tracked up to here and I mean he's
sent him hard
Jake okay she's right here guys she's
right here
I know Jay come here
let's back up out of here I'm confident
Emma's right back here or has just
literally like bolted through
but because she is so small with this
High Grass I mean it's like finding a
needle and Haystack right here there's
just a way
um she's going to send us coming up on
her way before I can even attempt to get
eyes on her
so right now my game plan is to back
Jake up out here Jake's job is finished
the focus now contain the Chihuahua
I'm just kind of exhausted
going because
keep going
with the sun setting the team agrees to
continue to work into the night
[Music]
all right
all right girlie where to Meanwhile
trustee is on the trail of Logan a
two-year-old Mini Labradoodle
he took off when Fourth of July
fireworks spooked him
my main concern about Logan is that he's
really cute and real friendly I'm
concerned that someone will come and
pick him up and take him home and then
not give him back I decided to find my
dog have him home safe okay come on
trustee tracked Logan for a couple of
hours throughout the neighborhood before
they got their first break
I heard a bark see there it is again
it didn't sound like it was a distress
call but it sounded like a dog was
barking
listen
that is his bark
man
there's a dog over there okay hope turns
to disappointment
negative he's a lab that's why it sounds
like him still no sign of Logan
we need to get some traps back here
trustee's given every indication this
afternoon that Logan is here so he
hasn't gotten far and we can possibly
stop him so he doesn't go any further
trustee fulfilled her duties and can
cool off in an air-conditioned car while
Wendy moves into phase two so I'd like
to see the Trap right in here
July you can hear the
fireworks going off crazy unfortunately
that has driven so many dogs away from
home and we're out here we're trying to
get this trap set up real quick
to get Logan Home Logan is likely hungry
cat food has a strong scent that carries
further than most dog food
if it lures Logan in his movement will
be captured on this trail cam for Wendy
to analyze
Bob is going out here and he's ran trail
from he
here all the way over to where the Trap
was
fireworks selling shotgun
80 miles away the search for Emma the
Chihuahua continues
they really just knew she was in that
brush area he just got really excited
we think we found her somewhere in here
this team is also using cat food
mixed with water to create a pungent
Chum Trail
second tactic is used
strips of cloth that have Stacy's scent
are placed to create a familiar
environment to ease Emma's anxiety
station here paired with the scent
strips the cat food is surrounded by
flour if Emma goes for the bait she'll
leave behind a trail of flower-coated
footprints
any activity in the area will be
recorded by this motion activated camera
providing valuable Intel for Carmen
so whatever comes and eats us food we're
gonna get on camera hopefully Emma
so let's uh see what happens okay
all right great
today was very challenging very
frustrating just because it's so hard to
be able to sit there and look at her and
just not get your hands on her
my main concern about MLB now right now
is that the weather's supposed to get
really bad
it's just kind of hard to go home
without her though because I know she's
still out there
okay
so she's out here another night
foreign
Stacy's ex-husband Mike drove 300 miles
with his fiance Holly to search the area
Emma was last spotted
she hates the rain wherever she is out
here now she's hunkered down the
distance trying not to get wet I just I
just wanted to be safe I just want to
get her back I don't really really care
about anything else
a combination of rain and fear likely
forced Emma into hiding
it's pretty empty their efforts are in
vain
then something catches Mike's eye Emma
are you kidding
predatory threat to a five pound dog
foxes thrive in Suburban areas where
they can both hunt and scavenge
[Applause]
definitely small enough for a fox to
want to grab hold of and make a meal out
of it
that's that's my primary concerns
getting her out of danger
two-year-old mini labradoodle Logan has
been missing for two days scared off by
4th of July fireworks
I'm not going to be able to get to this
this is my best friend it's worse than
it
[Music]
trustee tracked the frightened dog to a
nearby stretch of woods so I'd like to
see the Trap right in here Wendy said a
trap and told the owners to alert the
surrounding neighborhood about the lost
dog
less than 24 hours later
[Music]
I got a phone call from the lady that
lived couple streets north of where
trusted last tracked him said that she
had him on the leash and please come
home and get them I ran over and picked
them up and it was like one big dust
ball
it didn't matter to me as long as I got
my dog back
his paws were so damaged that he
couldn't walk on him for almost two
weeks
he's kind of back to normal he wants to
be right biased even more I think he's
afraid of just as much as we are to be
separated again
it's like my best friend
he is my best buddy
right I am so glad he's home with you
guys it makes me so happy and when we
get to celebrate like we are now with
Logan it just makes it so much worth it
best thing we ever do I love you trusty
foreign
she does amazing work she don't move
fast but she gets to where she wants to
be we owe her Logan's life
80 miles west another tracking team is
on the hunt for Emma a Chihuahua on the
run for four days
Carmen spotted the fast-moving dog on
railroad tracks next to a busy highway
nobody else she's so tiny this is went
home right now
thanks to Jake they know she's here
somewhere
Carmen has the family paper the area
with Flyers
and it works
look what I found she's right along the
side of the road I got a call from a
gentleman who saw one of the Flyers is
right where Jake thoughts he was
found her alongside here getting right
across the road
we gotta go home now
Mike immediately brings Emma to see
Stacy
I found
she was on the side of the road right
where Jake's are
[Music]
[Music]
you want to come to us huh
we missed you ready to go home with
Daddy come here
she's been out too long after six days
on her own Emma is readjusting to life
at home
foreign she's sleepy and she's being
very clingy and she's probably lost
about two pounds and she didn't have
that much to lose anyway but other than
that she feels fine as soon as she got
here she went back to her routine
[Music]
everybody's happy it was it was a big
load off everybody's mind everybody's
happy to have her home
this is the best part of my job just
making everybody happy and bringing the
pets home
reunited
foreign still in his rookie season of
tracking every meal is an opportunity to
hone scipio's skills
Belgian Malinois may not be as well
known as Bloodhounds and German
Shepherds but they are gaining
popularity in military and police
service in the United States and for
good reason
he's very alert he's very easily trained
because he wants to please and when he's
on it he will take me through thick and
thin and I can just hang on
for dear life yes
Scipio and his Handler Clementine are
off to track an older lab named Bobby
that's been missing for two days
here we go
Bobby was actually a foster he was
neglected it was very sad and very
traumatic he was just colored up tied to
a tree and forgotten about and so he's
always been very skittish around people
and he's super sweet he's
not you know fearful and he's not
aggressive he's just skittish this was
the silliest thing in the world
groceries out of the car
right into the front door
and I just didn't close it hard enough
like that but that was it I mean it was
it was like that I came back out of the
kitchen not a sign not a sound not a
bark not a jingle of the chain nothing
nowhere to be seen
the neighborhood is surrounded on three
sides by the water and then the fourth
side is this massive Bank of forest
we're pretty certain he's in the woods
just narrowing down the area would be a
massive help
Bobby has been spotted since his escape
a woman reported seeing him less than
two miles from Keith's home
she said she saw him out of her window
of this house towards the edge of her
property with these power lines
okay so where do you think was the dog
was sighted along here somewhere I think
along the edge
and give him some breath
[Applause]
like Coonhounds Belgian Malinois have an
abundance of energy scipio's patient
tracking approach though so I think
contrast the coonhound's headstrong
Style
Scipio processes
before committing to a scent Trail
he's interested in something
what we're going to be looking for are
hot spots so we use these dogs like a
tool he will get excited if he smells
your dog
so he's definitely pulling me in a
direction here
for something
yeah
this is good
Bobby Moe
he's following he's following a path
here
scipio's Behavior indicates Bobby used
the clearing under the power lines like
a highway that dog was definitely
pulling something
here we go there's the nose
sign when he's like adamant about taking
me somewhere then that means it's a hot
spot
track beers onto a small path
so this is all really hot when he's
pulling that's like really really good
Bobby may be close
the search for Bobby a lab mix takes a
critical turn
what he's pulling
so this is all really hot
IPO signals that Bobby was here recently
and may be nearby all right well
I'm hoping that he's still around you
somewhere but um let's do the Trap and
get that set before it gets dark all
right cool scipio's ability to perform
under pressure is in his blood Malinois
are a variety of Belgian Shepherd Dogs
the first dogs used by the Allies as
Messengers in World War One
having completed his task the focus
shifts to trapping
sweet he absolutely likes the softest
spot alive he's the guy that will jump
up on the bed lie down on the pillow oh
fantastic work
it's getting kind of dark dusk is when
they start to come out the dogs and out
of hiding because everything else seems
to settle down and they start looking
for food
I think it's good this is a step in the
right direction and obviously there's a
little heartbreak that we didn't find
Bobby but clearly that wasn't
necessarily going to be the you know the
guaranteed thing
overall gives a little hope I think
just a matter of getting them
[Music]
working dogs have a reputation for being
all business
[Music]
some though have a work hard play hard
mentality I don't have my own dog right
now my canine partner is Gretel
she's a black German Shepherd
every time she sees me she gets really
excited she knows we're gonna go work
now let go Alicia okay
Gretel and Janelle are on their way to
Joppa Maryland tasked with tracking down
an elderly cat
affectionately called kitten
Teresa told she's really not the
prettiest of patterns but she's got such
a great personality and she likes to
wrap her little paws around her arm so
that you pet her even more
I've had a lot of cats in my life his
kidney is just different you know I
always say if you're lucky enough that
kitten you've been lucky enough you know
nobody saw when or how kitten got out
Sharon and her husband speculate the cat
escaped down a staircase into the
backyard
I really like this cat and uh then you
start thinking it's been too long you
know because of her age and it's not
knowing
I'm really worried about her because
she's old she's 16 years old she has
arthritis
I want her home that's wonderful
I want her to be in bed tonight I like
she kisses my nose and she takes her
little paw and ever so gently
touches me and I miss that
the backyard is Sharon's best guess for
where kitten ran away
I took
[Music]
kitten has spent years playing in this
yard her scent is scattered all around
[Music]
so we're just working through the yard
Gretel Works to find a fresh Trail
I'm interest going over going over shed
S I think she might have gotten through
the fence here
oh okay that's definitely the way she's
interested in okay
can we get into your neighbor's yard
yeah I told him to keep their dog in
okay
come on Gretel
cats generally when they get out they
only go a couple houses away from where
they got out from whether it's behind
the house or in front of the house or to
either side so it's normally a shorter
track cats are tricky creatures they
hide under stuff and in things and
places you don't think to look even ones
that don't have closets you get up trees
so she came across this yard really hard
I guess she looks a little more
energetic now yeah
she's definitely
moving in this direction good job she's
tracking
[Music]
across the state the simple Act of
placing Flyers is the turning point in
an effort to recover a lost dog named
Bobby
after the track with Clementine we saw
solid leads Bobby was obviously in that
vicinity the community and the support
has been phenomenal
a wave of sightings rolled in
one voicemail stood out
it was from about 8 30 in the morning
and I think I saw your dog on the side
of the road it was a highway Bobby is so
skittish and so scared still of so many
different things I was just convinced
that he wouldn't be anywhere near a
highway
[Music]
I knew it was him from The Moment I Saw
that's exactly how he looked like when
he was laying down you know you'd see
his little white paws and see the little
brindle on his nose and then as I got
closer it started to sink in that he was
gone
that's where it ended where I found them
on the road and so
[Music]
you know we're on our half acre and we
have our big hill I just you know one
more game of fetch down the hill because
he uh
loved it and if I could sit back here
one more time and
and throw down and throw down and have
them run back up the hill and you know
he loved it
man
very difficult to come walking back in
and not have that extra Four Paws around
you know looking for the head rubbing
looking for the ear scratch
good job she's tracking the track heats
up in the search for a calico cat named
kitten
I'm really worried about her because
she's old and just the thought of not
knowing
you know follow our first year again or
what happened to her is just horrible
so she came across this yard really hard
because she looks a little more
energetic now yeah she's definitely
moving in this direction
Gretel signals so that means that's it
yeah
oh no kitten scent is gone
[Music]
it could mean the cat was picked up from
here by a neighbor
or worse
imagination is a brutal thing sometimes
dogs wild animals you know I mean that's
that's
that would be the worst case
suffering yeah I mean she doesn't
deserve that I mean yes
she's a she doesn't deserve this
the owners are always anxious their hope
is that you can find them their pet I
would love nothing more than a happy
ending for every track we go out on
the next step for them is to put feeding
stations on both sides of their house
so you want the cat to come on leave the
Paw Prints eat some food the flower
sticks to their pads and you get a
little Trail going off the cardboard too
and use what we call Chum Trails which
is the cat food mixed in water and then
a little bit more flyers in the area to
try to generate more sightings we need
more people to be aware that the cat's
missing you want to make sure that like
all the postal people know that the
cat's missing
it's really quiet I never thought of
that my work I mean
we'll find out yeah
so it's doing something
[Music]
today is a very exciting day for us
we're finally getting to see our brand
new puppies
three Fresh Faces have arrived and wills
hopes to turn them into world-class
trackers
Tucker a Labrador Retriever
rhaegar
and brick both Belgian Malinois we have
two trackers that do not have a dog
and that's Janelle and Carmen so today
we are going to see who matches up with
Who as a Tracker this is definitely this
is a dream come true this is a goal that
I've been working towards for years I am
super excited about today because I am
potentially going to meet my new partner
this is pretty close to Christmas
morning you know I got my fingers
crossed and maybe I'll be lucky enough
to get one
it's exciting this is the next
generation of dogs coming through the
program which is great oh
oh these beautiful
it would be kind of exciting to have a
malawa even though uh they are a bit of
a uh
a bit of a train wreck sometimes when
you're living with them your house
suffers
brick stands out he has a white tuft of
hair on his chest and a bigger stronger
physique than rhaegar
difference in
the end oh he's beautiful
as far as rhaegar you know he's a little
bit more timid wasn't so sure of himself
Tucker the lab had a normal lab happy to
see everybody if you pet me you're my
friend kind of personality which is
great hi Andy
Carmen and Janelle both want to pick
their first tracking dog
as lead tracker that decision is
ultimately Anne's
I'm trying to evaluate each dog get a
feel for how he does with everybody
you got to make a decision
while Anne continues to evaluate
concern for a lost cat named kitten is
taking a physical toll on one of her
owners Charlie
we went to the emergency room this
morning I feel like kitten missing is
causing the stress that caused Charlie
to have this heart problem this morning
so all week long we have been hunting
for the cat we've been putting posters
up we come out and do feeding stations
and it's just been on and on and on and
it's it's stressful because we don't we
don't see her and I think you know he's
taking it pretty hard and I do believe
that it had a lot to do with his
well-being
[Music]
it's just
he's been very stressed
Charlie's stress level could come down
now that there's a solid lead in
kitten's case we've been putting out
feeding stations every night around
eight o'clock and the first night when I
came out I did see some cat prints on
the left hand side of the house and some
of the cat food had been eaten this
morning on that side there were a lot of
paw prints so there was a lot of
activity of an animal going around which
I think was a cat I'm hoping it was
kitten there's not a lot of loose cats
around here
putting the feeding stations down has
given me a lot more hope than if I had
plus if she's here she's and that's her
she's eating I have her water around she
could be drinking
so that's comforting yes it definitely
gives me more hope I'm glad they showed
me how to do that
Sharon is continuing to bait traps with
cat food and using foliage to camouflage
them
I also put in a sock of mine so that she
had my scent I feel helpful I think if
she's still walking on this Earth she's
going to walk in one of these traps
tonight I feel pretty good about that I
really do I hope you know tomorrow I can
call you and say she's home
the case of kitten a missing elderly cat
is beginning to crack open I was looking
at the back window of the house to see
if I needed to cut the grass and I saw a
dark spot in the yard
[Music]
seeing the posters around the
neighborhood for the last 10 days
thought to myself I hope that's not you
know the cat that's missing
but it was
she was laying there Motionless
feared the worst and uh
I went I reached down touched her hip
and she raised her head
so I was like thank God
for 16 years old
she she looked like she was doing okay
I want to thank all their neighbors if
it weren't for them we would have never
found them oh thank you thank you nice
meeting you Charlie thank you with a
clean bill of health Charlie is out of
the hospital to reunite with kittens
I was petting her on the way to the
emergency room and she kept putting her
little head in my hand and she had been
hurt and I I felt like of course I
wanted her to make it but I felt like I
even if she didn't make it that she was
found and she knew that we loved her and
I would be there with her and um
but she didn't make it
[Music]
oh my goodness
how's she doing
oh hi honey bunny wasn't it is the
difference isn't it oh she's so super
sweet oh she I know she might love me
she had a very serious wound on her back
that we have been um flushing and
cleaning it looks like it could be from
another cat bite wound a couple days
outside you know she's not into eight
days good I mean that's a long time
I'm just so happy that you guys could
take care of her and save her for me
a relief
happy I just feel lucky
a little lucky
[Music]
beside your daddy
look at her oh
you see she puts her little Paul off she
wants to
he said Daddy
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
and wills evaluates Tucker a Labrador
Retriever and two Belgian Malinois timid
rhaegar and confident brick turn around
look here comes brick Oh my God he is
bigger
click
he's a sweetie pie yeah
I think that was awesome yeah yeah you
fell in love with them didn't you Tucker
the lab is a lovebug
his nose is phenomenal and I love a lab
for tracking
you got to make a decision
Janelle and Carmen would love to pick
their own dog but his lead tracker Anne
has the only vote today
they're all nice dogs they're all super
intense on the nose
for Carmen and his chosen Tucker a
friendly Labrador
Tucker he'd be the best fit for you yes
rhaegar is a little bit still on the shy
side brick is going to require a little
bit more harder stronger Handler
a much higher intensity yeah he is
brick the bigger more aggressive Belgian
Malinois is chosen for Janelle
it's going to be a ton of fun you can be
a good dog
as for rhaegar the smaller timid Belgian
Malinois and decides he is getting a new
home as well I have always root for the
underdog the one that you know is shy I
want to bring him out I want to love up
all on him so Radar's going to come home
with me
I am excited these dogs will go home
with their new handlers their trackers
for the first week we're gonna do
nothing but just play with them get them
to eat out of our hands love on them and
then maybe the third or fourth week we
might start doing a little bit of
tracking with them
under Ann's guidance this is the newest
class of trackers
it'll take about three months of
teaching them and then before the end of
the year they'll be out working saving
lives
[Music]
[Music]